all right y'all i am running late as
usual today is game day we are driving
six hours
for a game i'm running late so hopefully
i make the bus
oh my god i'm running late um so i'm
meeting the girls at this train station
and that's where we're all gonna leave
from
some
would say it's not good to get coffee in
a time like this when i'm running late
right but others would say
that it's even more needed right because
your girl is tired i'm really confused
because this station like it's like a
shopping mall
see this is what we're looking at
hello um can i do
a latte
um
i'm american
so can i have like the sweetest thing
you have
no no no coffee like like sweetest like
remember i'm american we're addicted to
sugar okay like
i mean
yeah yeah
you get me i think
[Music]
you get me
you get me yeah
okay i know my nutritionist told me to
stop drinking coffee
and i know every vlog i say i'm gonna
stop drinking it
so i'm gonna just stop promising you
guys this to be honest i don't know why
i give you guys false hope every single
time
next step i gotta find the girl now
again again i don't know i'm like that
and i get kind of weird throwing cameras
in people's faces
we'll see we'll see if they're into it i
don't know this is only my second
basketball game here
oh my god guys i'm so mad the one thing
about the uk
this [ __ ] is so disorganized here apart
from stupid what's your name
pearl well and this is an awesome little
uh tripod isn't it yeah
i'm so tired pearl do you live in the uk
yeah can i borrow you very quickly for
prostate cancer uk tell you what we're
doing as a charity we are actually
amazing to be involved with this i'll be
the kind of great behind-the-scene guy
but not so much in front um
i'm in like
men's
content basically like man dating advice
oh that's perfect i wasn't saying men's
content was such a broad thing then that
it it was either something like date
advice clothing advice or only fans and
i wasn't really sure what
could we get you on board with a monthly
donation okay
okay
you should be like jumping at the chance
of helping charities no i'm pretty broke
i don't know let's go
thanks
i was like you're barking up the wrong
tree sir
like respectfully that sounds like a
good charity i think my grandpa died of
that
but yeah you will not catch me
[Music]
it will not maybe maybe one day when i
have more money charity will be on the
table
i
got here they said to get here at 12.
i got here at 1203
and i'm on the phone with my coach
and i say
do i have time to get coffee
the man tells me yes
you do have time to get coffee
so
i'm like okay cool i'm chilling
and then i look down and they're like oh
the train doesn't come thomas is leaving
in five minutes i'm like it's leaving in
five minutes
why did you tell me did i have enough
time to get caught
so i don't know where i'm going i'm in a
different country at this big ass
station and i'm like there's all these
different like stations next to each
other and i'm just so confused about
where to go i guess i missed the first
train right
remember everyone else but like two
other girls make this train
and i'm like cool okay these two other
girls will tell me where to go and all
of a sudden when i'm buying my ticket
they're gone i'm like what the [ __ ]
and i get this call and they're like you
need to run to this other station
to make this train and i'm like
you're you're kidding
oh my god my bags are so bad i need to
get sleep and so i'm running i'm running
i think i'm gonna make it
i see the train leaving i did not in
fact make it and now the next train
isn't for an hour i was so mad and i'll
tell you why i was mad
because in the u.s
we would all meet
like at the school and go to the train
together but here it's like fend for
yourself and i i'm barely on this team
okay i'm barely on this team because
i
i'm on the volleyball team i only go to
basketball games when we don't have a
game which is like never
so i would think knowing that this is
the one girl who doesn't doesn't know
anything
barely is on this team isn't from london
one of the only americans that's enough
you would
help me
figure out where i'm going
oh my god why did he tell me that i had
enough time to get coffee i clearly
didn't
i'm mad
but
you know
it is what it is
i've come to the conclusion
this was my fault
i should have made sure
where i was going
before getting coffee
i called my dad i was really mad he said
this is your own fault
so i'll stay on camera this is my own
fault but he shouldn't have told me
that i had time
i'm just saying
at least i'm on the train now
so it's like a two-hour
train ride and i'll probably get like
some work done for my
i
channel
this is just the worst day ever
i do youtube
i made it before the game shockingly
surprisingly
i'm gonna get ready
yeah i'll keep you like guys posted
hopefully
it goes better than last time
all right guys this is the court
we're gonna warm up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys i'm continuing the vlog
i'm not going to show you guys the
scoreboard because it's kind of
embarrassing
but it didn't go well i'm not going to
lie
okay
[Music]
good game
good game
[Applause]
i think we play a constellation game in
like three weeks